buenas noches
parece que fuera solo ayer cuando
estábamos en nuestra primera convención
donde mi esposo aceptó la nominación
republicana y después se convirtió en
nuestro presidente número 45 de eeuu y
el entusiasmo de esta nación es real
tanto ahora como hace cuatro años sé que
hablo por mi esposo y por toda la
familia cuando digo que no hemos
olvidado a las personas increíbles que
están dispuestos a apostar por un hombre
de negocios que nunca había trabajado en
política sabemos que fueron ustedes
quienes lo eligieron para ser comandante
en jefe y sabemos que son ustedes
quienes nos van a llevar al más allá de
la línea de meta de nuevo gracias a su
gran apoyo entonces y aún seguimos
agradecidos por ese apoyo quiero
reconocer el hecho
y desde marzo nuestras vidas han
cambiado de manera drástica el enemigo
invisible 19 llegó a nuestro hermoso
país y tuvo un impacto en todos nosotros
mi simpatía para todos aquellos que han
perdido a un ser querido en mis
oraciones están con aquellos que están
enfermos o están sufriendo y sé que
muchas personas se sienten ansiosas y
muchas no saben qué hacer quiero que
sepan que no están solos en la
administración de mi esposo no va a
dejar de luchar hasta que exista un
tratamiento efectivo o una vacuna
disponible para cada uno
donald no va a descansar hasta que haya
hecho todo lo que puede para cuidar a
todos los impactados por esta terrible
pandemia
quiero extender mi gratitud a todos los
trabajadores de la salud a los
trabajadores de primera línea
y profesores que han salido adelante en
estos tiempos difíciles a pesar de los
riesgos para ustedes y para sus propias
familias ustedes han puesto primero a su
país y mi esposo y yo nos sentimos
agradecidos
me llama y me ha sentido conmovida por
la manera como los estadounidenses se
han unido en esta situación que puede
asustar es en tiempos como estos que
podemos al cual miraremos desde el
futuro y diremos que a través de la
compasión la fortaleza la amabilidad la
determinación fuimos capaces de
restaurar la promesa de nuestro futuro
los negocios salieron adelante y también
los voluntarios y las personas quisieron
compartir sus ideas sus recursos y su
apoyo de todo tipo con sus vecinos y con
las personas que no conocían igualmente
así ha sido muy inspirador ver cómo las
personas de esta gran nación pueden
hacer unos por otros especialmente
cuando estamos en nuestro momento más
frágil
hablando de fortaleza y determinación
recientemente celebramos el aniversario
número 100 de la enmienda 19 y generar
al norte de la casa blanca mostramos una
exhibición dedicada al voto femenino
a los niños del país que enviarán
mejoras de arte
para este para conmemorar este tiempo
importante en historia las mujeres que
reflejaban el impacto de la voz femenina
en la historia de este país y que tan
orgullosa me sentiré de votar nuevamente
por 2 en noviembre debemos asegurarnos
que las mujeres sean escuchadas y que el
sueño americano continúa triunfando y
creciendo en eslovenia que estaba bajo
el comunismo siempre escuchaba de un
lugar increíble llamado américa un lugar
que defendía la libertad y la
oportunidad a medida que crecía se
convirtió en mi objetivo ir a eeuu y
seguir mi trabajo en la industria de la
moda
mis padres trabajaron duro para asegurar
que nuestra familia no solamente pudiera
vivir y prosperar en estados unidos sino
también pudieran contribuir a la nación
que le permite a la gente llegar con un
sueño y hacer que ese sueño se convierta
en realidad
quiero tomar un momento para agradecer a
mi madre a mi padre por todo lo que han
hecho por nuestra familia es por ustedes
que estoy aquí el día de hoy
[Aplausos]
y los estados unidos cuando tenía 26
años working entre libia y trabajaba en
la tierra de la oportunidad era un sueño
hecho realidad pero yo quería más quería
hacer una ciudad después de 10 años de
papeleos y paciencia entre estudié para
la prueba y en 2006 me convertí en un
ciudadano estadounidense
y testigos van de progres momento sigue
siendo los momentos de mayor orgullo en
mi vida porque con trabajo duro y
determinación pude lograr mi propio
sueño americano como una inmigrante y
una mujer independiente comprendía lo
que significa el privilegio de vivir
aquí y poder disfrutar de las libertades
y las oportunidades que tenemos
eso es lady como primera dama he tenido
la fortuna de ver el sueño americano
volverse realidad una y otra vez
he conocido a muchas mujeres
inspiradoras niños padres y familias que
han superado problemas incluyendo la
adicción
la falta de hogar
miembros de la familia enfermos muertos
muchos abusos y muchos retos
quería que muchos se rindieran en los
últimos tres años y medio
claramente han sido inolvidables no hay
palabras para describir lo honrada lo
humilde que me siento y también lo
afortunada de poder servir
en esta nación como su primera dama
después de muchas de las experiencias
que he tenido no sé si realmente puedo
explicar totalmente cuántas personas me
llevo a casa en el corazón cada día
desde los soldados valientes que dejan
tanto atrás para que podamos ser libres
hasta los niños de todas las
circunstancias que he conocido alrededor
del mundo
muchas gracias por inspirarme
es el mayor honor poder servirles cuando
hablo con miembros de las fuerzas
militares a pesar de los tiempos de
sacrificio con sus familias ya haber
experimentado la guerra o haber sufrido
una pérdida no tienen lamentos de haber
servido a este país los mismos va para
las familias y de los trabajadores de
primera línea cuando esas personas salen
y no saben si o cuando volverán
o cuando hablo con familias
y han perdido área es un dolor mezclado
con orgullo y eso es algo en lo que
pienso muy seguido entonces gracias a
todos aquellos que sirven a nuestro país
en las fuerzas militares y como
trabajadores de emergencia y también
gracias a las familias que esperan por
ellos ustedes también son nuestros
héroes
y me he sentido como vida por los niños
y en las familias con los cuales he
pasado tiempo en eso en hospitales en
escuelas y en otras ubicaciones
alrededor del país o niños que se están
enfrentando al dolor
[Música]
a la enfermedad que acabaría incluso con
el adulto más fuerte padres que se
despiertan para saber si sus hijos aún
están vivos si ellos son un testamento a
lo que pueda ser nuestra confianza en la
medicina y en la ciencia en el primer
viaje como primera dama el exterior mi
esposo y yo visitamos lugares de gran
significado para las tres grandes
religiones isla más el cristianismo y el
judaísmo
tengo una memoria de ese viaje es una
joven que tuve el privilegio de visitar
mientras estuve en un hospital de roma
italia
allí le leí una pequeña historia y
aprendí que él y su familia habían
estado esperando un corazón durante
mucho tiempo y él tenía un pronóstico
difícil esta historia nos hizo llorar y
volamos
a bélgica para la siguiente parte del
viaje
para aterrizar sólo a una horas después
aprendimos que un corazón había sido
donado y que iría para ese niño si
pienso en él muchas veces junto a otros
pacientes fuertes y valientes en todo
este país
otros ejemplos inevitables de esta
fortaleza del carácter estadounidense
han aparecido en las comunidades que han
sido impactadas por los desastres
naturales los huracanes los tornados y
las inundaciones muestran el lado oscuro
de la madre naturaleza pero después
también nos muestran un lado hermoso de
la humanidad mi esposo y yo hemos
visitado muchos lugares que han sido
afectados por los desastres naturales y
nos sentimos conmovidos por la fortaleza
de las personas que han perdido todo
y la amabilidad de los vecinos y las
comunidades y la característica común en
todas estas situaciones es la
determinación inquebrantable para
ayudarnos unos a otros reconozco las
historias que acabo de contar son de
personas que han sobrevivido a
circunstancias extraordinarias pero
donald y yo también nos sentimos
inspirados por los millones de
estadounidenses que se despiertan cada
día
con un objetivo simple de proveer para
sus familias y mantenerlas seguras
ustedes son la espina dorsal de este
país ustedes son las personas que
continúan haciendo que eeuu de américa
lo que es
y que tienen la increíble
responsabilidad de preparar a las
próximas generaciones para dejar todo
aún mejor de lo que encontraron
así como ustedes están luchando por sus
familias mi esposo y nuestra familia y
las personas de esta administración
estamos aquí luchando por ustedes no
importa la cantidad de titulares en
negativos o mentirosos por parte de los
medios donald trump
no va a perder el foco en ese objetivo
el ama este país y él sabe cómo hacer
las cosas como han aprendido en los
últimos cinco años él no es un político
tradicional él no solamente habla él
pide acción y obtiene resultados en el
futuro de nuestro país siempre ha sido
muy importante para él y es algo que
siempre he admirado de hecho de crear un
mejor futuro para las próximas
generaciones y es por eso que lancé la
iniciativa be best para ayudarlos a
alcanzar su máximo potencial
bieber tiene un único objetivo enseñarle
a la juventud la importancia de su
bienestar tanto mental como físico
también incluye comprender la seguridad
online y los peligros del abuso de los
opioides y las drogas a través de best
el cargo y yo hemos podido crear
programas a través de organizaciones que
están haciendo cosas extraordinarias en
nuestro país y alrededor del mundo hay
continuó feliz continúo creyendo que
está creando una luz sobre estos
ejemplos positivos otros alrededor del
país y del mundo se inspirarán para
hacer su parte por nuestra próxima
generación a ayudar a los niños no es un
tema político es nuestro imperativo
moral cuando pienso en un momento
esencial de be best
pienso en un viaje que hice a áfrica en
ese vasto y hermoso continente puedes
visitar los países de ghana malawi kenia
y egipto y una de esas visitas en
particular
tuvo un impacto muy profundo en mí
en ghana en la costa fue la primera
parada de ese viaje a y experimenté de
primera mano a sus personas cálidas y
sus bellas tradiciones a estando allí
visité a que el castillo de cape coast
guía aprendí más sobre un viaje cruel en
la era del intercambio de esclavos me
sentí horrorizada cuando escuchaba al
guía contándome tantas historias
inhumanas y creé una nueva perspectiva y
stay de ese momento en la historia que
nunca debemos olvidar para que podamos
asegurarnos que nunca ocurra nuevamente
como todos ustedes
he pensado en el tema racial que sacude
al país es una dura realidad que no nos
sentimos orgullosos de partes de nuestra
historia y aliento a las personas para
que se enfoquen en nuestro futuro
mientras aún puedan aprender de nuestro
pasado debemos recordar que hoy todos
somos una sola comunidad
religión formada de muchas razas
religiones y etnias history nuestra
historia diversa es lo que hace que este
país sea fuerte y aún así aún tenemos
tanto por aprender unos de otros con eso
quiero hacer un llamado a los ciudadanos
de este país para que puedan tomar un
momento una pausa y miren a las cosas
desde todas las perspectivas
urko a las personas para que se unan de
manera cívica para que podamos vivir
según nuestros estándares de ideales
estadounidenses y también le pidió a las
personas que detengan la violencia y los
robos que se hacen en el nombre de la
justicia y nunca hagan asunciones
basados en el color de la piel de una
persona en lugar de derribar cosas
pensemos en nuestros
errores sintamos orgullosos de nuestra
evolución y miremos el camino hacia el
futuro
todos los días recordemos que somos una
sola nación bajo dios y que tenemos que
querernos unos a otros y apreciarlos y
es paul la administración de mi esposo
ha trabajado para tratar de crear un
cambio cuando se trata de temas y
problemas alrededor de la raza y la
religión en el país es el primer
presidente que
he hablado desde la asamblea general de
la onu haciendo un llamado a los países
del mundo para acabar con la persecución
política y religiosa y honrar el derecho
de cada persona de orar como bien lo
escoja ha hecho inversiones sustanciales
en las universidades históricamente
negras y en las universidades también
continúa luchando por la posibilidad de
elegir el colegio dándole a los padres
la posibilidad de que sus hijos
florezcan él sabe cómo crear
pero cambio desde el día que lo conocí
solamente ha querido hacer que este país
sea el mejor que puede ser durante
muchos años estuve frustrado y
preocupado y me siento tan orgullosa de
ver que las cosas que ha hecho en tan
poco tiempo en eeuu está en su corazón
y aunque el momento solamente podamos
ver lo peor de las personas y de los
políticos en las noticias recordemos
cómo podemos unirnos en los momentos más
difíciles
craig y aunque el debate continúa por
los temas raciales concentrémonos en los
avances que hemos lo alcanzado y
trabajemos juntos en un mejor mañana
para todos nuestra administración
también ha dado recursos históricos y
generado resultados y creando conciencia
alrededor del abuso de drogas y los
opioides especialmente para los niños
muchas veces en los titulares están
llenos de chismes
yo quisiera tomar este momento para
alentar a los medios a concentrarse aún
más en la crisis de drogas que enfrenta
el país esta enfermedad es una que
afecta a todos y no le importará el
estatus socioeconómico la raza o la edad
esta adicción ha golpeado cada parte de
la sociedad y ahora mucho más que antes
tenemos programas en la medicina para
poder combatirlo solo tenemos que poder
hablar de esto de manera abierta y
ustedes los medios tienen la plataforma
para hacer que eso ocurra
a la industria de los medios y al país
les pido que todos nos comprometamos
para ayudar en la lucha en contra de la
adicción a las drogas hablando de esto
aún más especialmente mientras luchamos
contra la pandemia del cob y tenemos que
recordar
los suicidios van en aumento
linas ya que hay personas que se están
enfrentando a la soledad y a la adicción
y piensan que no tienen un lugar a donde
acudir por favor padres enseñarles a sus
hijos los profesores también los
legisladores aprueben legislaciones para
ayudar a aquellos que necesitan ayuda y
hacerlo de manera segura y sin miedo y
dando recursos a las organizaciones que
ayudan a las personas que han sido
impactadas por la adicción estigma
extremo cuando se acaba el estigma la
gente ya no tendrá vergüenza de
solicitar ayuda y sus vidas estarán más
seguras y serán salvadas si ustedes
tienen problemas con la adicción no hay
vergüenza con esta enfermedad por favor
busquen ayuda ustedes se lo merecen hoy
mis próximos cuatro años como primera
dama continuará construyendo su
reconstruido con be best
apoyaremos la aprobación de
legislaciones para los más vulnerables y
continuaré con el trabajo que he
comenzado con los niños así como en las
comunidades y en las naciones tribales
quiero asegurarme que los niños están
siendo protegidos y las comunidades
tengan los recursos para poder combatir
la adicción a las drogas y el abuso
infantil como mi esposo y la esta
administración continuará alentando la
educación que apoye las necesidades
individuales de los niños es vital que
los niños tengan los bloques para poder
construir su futuro y su éxito también
continuará con el trabajo de restaurar
esta casa que es un gran símbolo de
orgullo para la gente de este país creo
que este hogar icónico debe ser
preservado y cuidado para que puedan ser
disfrutados por el pueblo de este país y
también para los visitantes del mundo
durante años
me siento apasionada por esta grande y
hermosa casa por todo lo que representa
y ahora tengo mensaje especial para las
madres de este país
y este mundo moderno avanza tan rápido y
nuestros hijos se enfrentan a retos que
parece que están cambiando cada pocos
meses justo como yo ustedes ven como
puede ser dañina en los medios sociales
dice que muchos de ustedes están
buscando respuestas sobre cómo hablar
con sus hijos sobre el lado peligroso de
la tecnología y las relaciones con otros
como cada padre en este país siento que
hay muchas lecciones que tenemos que
enseñarle a nuestros hijos y las
responsabilidades para las madres no
están solamente ahí para hacerlas todas
tenemos
me acuerdo que tengo soy muy afortunada
y hay días en los que busco fortaleza y
sabiduría para hacer lo mejor que pueda
por él por mi hijo
para las madres y padres en todo el
mundo
ustedes son guerreros en mi esposo
ustedes tienen un presidente que no va a
dejar de luchar por ustedes y sus
familias
veo lo duro que pelean día y noche y a
pesar de ataques sin precedentes de la
oposición y los medios él no se va a
rendir y él simplemente trabaja más duro
[Aplausos]
es un esposo que me apoya en todo lo que
hago ha construido una administración
con un número sin precedente de mujeres
en cargos de liderazgo y ha creado un
ambiente donde el pueblo estadounidense
siempre es la prioridad y él le da la
bienvenida a diferentes puntos de vista
y le gusta pensar por fuera de la caja
sé que hablo por mi esposo y por la
familia cuando digo que estamos muy
agradecidos porque le dieron la
confianza de ser nuestro presidente y
estaremos honrados de poder servir este
país por cuatro años más
[Aplausos]
harding como han escuchado no quiero
utilizar este tiempo precioso atacando
al otro lado porque como vimos la semana
pasada esto solamente sirve para dividir
aún más a la nación estoy aquí porque
necesitamos que no es que mi esposo sea
presidente y comandante en jefe por
cuatro años más
antes él es lo mejor para este país
todos conocemos